c'est difficile à croire mais oui ce
drone que j'ai pourtant acheté à Paris
dans un centre commercial peut tuer il y
a quelques semaines j'ai été en Ukraine
et on a vu sur place comme on les drones
comme celui-ci sont devenus une arme à
part entière
bravo
en réalité le drone n'est pas une
invention si récente les origines du
drone remontent au début du 20e siècle
donc avant d'avoir un drone qui
ressemblait à ça et bien on avait des
drones qui ressemblaient à ça alors oui
là j'en suis conscient on voit pas grand
chose mais j'y peux rien on est en 1923
en tout cas le tout premier drone
français et conçu cette année-là par ces
deux hommes max boucher et Maurice
Percheron bon et vous le voyez à ce
moment là ça ressemble plutôt à un petit
avion à hélice mais il est radiocommandé
et donc sans pilote à bord et ça
franchement en 1923 c'est une révolution
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis
comment est-on passé d'un petit avion
qui vole tout seul à une arme capable de
tuer et surtout pourquoi est-ce que ça
change tout dans la guerre en Ukraine et
quelle question notamment éthique est-ce
que ça peut poser c'est ce que l'on va
voir aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bon je vais pas vous faire toutes
l'évolution depuis le premier drone
français mais l'intérêt rennait à partir
de la seconde guerre mondiale en fait
les pays font alors face à d'importantes
pertes des pertes matérielles et des
pertes humaines le tout dans les airs
les différents états en guerre
commencent alors à développer des avions
qui pourraient voler sans pilotes et
enregistrer les informations permettant
ensuite de mieux attaquer l'idée est
donc poser et ses avions drones sont
créés enfin presque finalement car d'un
point de vue technologique c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué lors de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale en effet les
systèmes de guidage ne sont pas assez
puissants pour être parfaitement
contrôlés à distance autrement dit ça ne
fonctionne pas pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale mais quelque chose qui apparaît
dans les années 60 va tout changer il
s'agit de l'informatique l'arrivée de
l'informatique permet en effet à ses
avions drones de pouvoir voler de
manière beaucoup plus précise à ce
moment là voilà à quoi ressemble le
drone de reconnaissance le plus
perfectionné en France en 1966 c'est le
Nord aviation et les Américains
développent aussi leur propre drone avec
le modèle fireby fun fact d'ailleurs à
ce sujet là c'est drone possédait leur
propre petit parachute un parachute
qu'il déployait à la fin de leur mission
pour atterrir justement en douceur et
très clairement ce serait pas forcément
discret aujourd'hui bref à partir de là
le développement de drone d'observation
s'accélère il devienne rapidement donc
présents sur toutes les grandes zones de
conflits qui ont marqué ce 20e siècle on
notera donc au passage qu'aujourd'hui on
est nombreux à pouvoir acheter des
drones comme ça directement dans un
centre commercial des drones qui
permettent de faire des images de grande
qualité ou alors d'ailleurs de s'amuser
mais ce qu'il faut donc comprendre et on
le voit ici c'est que le développement
technologique des drones a été poussé au
départ par des questions d'armement bref
pour un pays avoir des drones c'est être
à la pointe de la technologie et donc
avoir une armée puissante et ça
l'Ukraine le comprend dès 2014 lorsque
la guerre commence dans le don une
région à l'Est du pays ainsi qu'en
Crimée une région donc a été envahie par
la Russie en 2014 à ce moment là
l'Ukraine comprend qu'elle ne comprend
rien finalement à ce qui se passe sur le
champ de bataille qu'elle n'a rien
finalement qui lui permet d'obtenir des
renseignements depuis les airs les
avions de combat et les hélicoptères
sont trop visibles et ils sont abattus
ça sonne donc comme un déclic pour le
gouvernement ukrainien et l'armée qui
veut trouver une façon de s'informer
différemment un programme de création de
drone est alors lancé et l'Ukraine
commence dans les années qui suivent à
former ces militaires à leur utilisation
elle crée même une unité dédiée à ce
travail de reconnaissance aérienne
l'aéro rose vidska qui rassemble en fait
des spécialistes informatiques bénévoles
dont l'objectif est de concevoir des
drones des drones qui seraient ensuite
utile à l'armée
et ça vous allez le voir sur le terrain
dans quelques instants ça change tout
quand la Russie a envahi l'Ukraine le 24
février 2022
[Musique]
la maîtrise du renseignement qui avait
fait finalement défaut aux forces
ukrainiennes en 2014 et aujourd'hui
devenu un atout majeur face aux forces
russes alors oui certes c'est lié au
renseignement fournis par les
Occidentaux et notamment les Américains
qui ont forcément apporté beaucoup
d'informations au gouvernement ukrainien
depuis le début de la guerre mais c'est
aussi lié à l'utilisation donc de ces
drones je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
mais dans les premiers jours de cette
guerre en Ukraine entre fin février et
début mars 2022 un immense qu'on voit
militaire russe qui s'étend sur plus de
60 km se dirigeait de roi vers la
capitale
ukrainienne qui et bien aujourd'hui on
sait que c'est grâce à ces drone et leur
capacité à surveiller ce qui se passait
aux alentours que l'armée ukrainienne a
réussi à empêcher donc cette attaque de
cuve des drones en fait dirigés par un
petit groupe d'une trentaine
d'Ukrainiens ont permis de repérer et de
détruire les véhicules en tête du convoi
ainsi que d'ailleurs des réserves
d'essence encore des réserves d'armes le
convarus c'est donc ensuite retrouver
complètement bloqué il n'a pas réussi à
avancer davantage cet épisode du grand
convoi militaire russe vers keV Marc
clairement tournant dans ce conflit et
les Ukrainiens comprennent alors que oui
c'est drôle peuvent faire la différence
dans la guerre
[Musique]
c'est intéressant d'ailleurs de noter
que c'est la première fois dans un
conflit armé qu'on entend parler du
détournement de drone des drones que
l'on peut trouver donc dans le commerce
ou près de chez vous sur la vidéo que
vous voyez ici on voit par exemple à un
soldat ukrainien qui utilise un drone
civil pour effectuer de la surveillance
militaire et sur cette vidéo on va même
encore plus loin puisque sur ce drone et
bien ils ont carrément ajouté des
petites charges explosives pour aller
directement les larguer sur l'ennemi
alors comment en est-on arrivé là en
Ukraine et bien dans les jours qui ont
suivi l'invasion russe les Ukrainiens
sont nombreux à vouloir s'engager pour
défendre leur pays le problème c'est que
la majorité d'entre eux n'ont aucune
formation militaire en revanche et bien
certains d'entre eux ont des compétences
dans des nouvelles technologies et en
informatique c'est volontaire vont donc
être recrutés pour transformer des
drones civils comme celui que j'ai de
mon côté pour les transformer et pour
former aussi d'autres volontaires à leur
utilisation
c'est un peu la suite de ce qui se
passait en 2014 finalement sauf que là
cette façon beaucoup plus importante
depuis 2022 et quand on est allé en
Ukraine avec mon équipe il y a quelques
semaines on s'est rendu justement dans
un de ces centres de formation de drone
près de cive d'ailleurs pour vous
expliquer à quel point c'est un sujet
qui est sensible l'adresse précise de
cette école n'est pas publique par
mesure de sécurité afin de rester donc
protégé d'éventuelles bombardements on a
donc eu rendez-vous à un endroit précis
au milieu de nulle part et ensuite on a
été escorté jusqu'au lieu d'entraînement
ce centre de formation a ouvert en avril
deux mois environ après le début de
l'invasion et depuis presque chaque jour
une vingtaine du crayon soldats comme
civil d'ailleurs sont formés directement
ici drone
mais dans cette guerre un autre type de
drone va faire son apparition d'ailleurs
des deux côtés il s'agit des drones
tueurs
les drones que vous voyez juste ici
c'est ce que l'on appelle des drones
kamikazes il transporte en fait des
explosifs ils sont pilotés ou alors
d'ailleurs programmé pour s'écraser et
exploser directement à l'impact sur la
cible depuis septembre la Russie frappe
régulièrement l'Ukraine avec ce modèle
de drone kamikaze ce modèle c'est le
chai de 136 un drone de fabrication
iranienne alors pourquoi est-ce que la
Russie comme l'Ukraine d'ailleurs
utilise des drones kamikazes ces
derniers mois et bien des deux côtés en
fait les stocks de missiles s'amenuisent
faut donc trouver une autre manière de
faire la guerre qui ne vit pas tout le
stock justement tout en restant
d'ailleurs le plus en retrait possible
pour éviter les pertes humaines et c'est
d'une certaine façon ce que permet de
cette drones kamikaze son plus petit que
des drones de combat classique ils sont
aussi moins chers à produire environ 20
000 euros par unité 20.000 euros ça peut
paraître un petit peu abstrait dit comme
ça mais c'est en réalité beaucoup moins
cher que certains missiles qui peuvent
dépasser les 100.000 euros et enfin il
faut noter que à leur arrivée et à leur
impact ils peuvent provoquer un bruit
très important un bruit qui selon
certains spécialistes n'est pas le fruit
du hasard et peut réellement avoir un
impact terrorisant sur la population
à noter que c'est drone kamikazes
viennent s'ajouter à d'autres types de
drones tueurs des drones de combat plus
classiques disons des drones qui peuvent
larguer des bombes les Etats-Unis par
exemple les ont beaucoup utilisé au
Moyen-Orient dans les années qui ont
suivi les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
on en reparle juste après sur tous les
débats éthiques qui l'entourent
[Musique]
c'est drone sont donc utilisés ces
derniers jours par les deux camps pour
attaquer mais ils sont aussi par
définition aussi une menace pour les
deux pays une menace dont il faut se
protéger
[Musique]
cette vidéo est devenue virale le 17
octobre 2022 on y voit des policiers
Ukrainiens tentant d'intercepter
directement depuis la rue les drones
kamikazes envoyés par la Russie et même
si la vidéo est impressionnante en
réalité c'est quasiment impossible de
stopper un drone de cette manière là
pour s'en protéger il faut des systèmes
de défense très développés dans le
centre de formation où nous nous sommes
rendus en Ukraine nous avons assisté à
des essais d'une arme de défense visant
à lutter contre les drones ennemis c'est
ce qu'ils appellent des brouilleurs
anti-drone
et rouba
c'est une arme spéciale météo
[Musique]
demain matin
alors pour le moment c'est brouilleur
sont surtout efficaces sur les drones
moins pointus que les drones kamikazes
mais vous vous en doutez les pays
développent constamment des nouveaux
systèmes pour tenter donc de faire face
assez drone bref voilà où nous en sommes
pour le moment
mais alors ces nouvelles technologies
peuvent-elles carrément un jour
remplacer les armes plus classiques de
la guerre ce qui est certain au regard
de la guerre nukraine c'est que
l'intérêt de posséder les deux des armes
technologiques et des armes plus
classiques et quelque chose d'important
pour les différentes armées mais alors
est-ce souhaitable bien il faut savoir
qu'actuellement les armées des grandes
puissances essaient de combiner deux
aspects à la fois la robotique avec par
exemple des drones mais aussi
l'intelligence artificielle
[Musique]
les entreprises travaillent donc au
développement de robots de combat des
robots qui auraient une forme
d'autonomie potentiellement sur leur
prise de décision et notamment sur des
questions cruciales comme par exemple le
choix de tuer ou non une personne alors
clairement dit comme ça ça peut
ressembler à un film de science-fiction
plutôt d'ailleurs de dystopie
utilisez des drones ou des robots
autonomes soulèvent en fait beaucoup de
questions éthiques et l'opinion publique
n'est d'ailleurs pas favorable au
développement de ces technologies de
plus en plus autonome remontons un peu
le temps une nouvelle fois nous sommes
dans les années 2010 en pleine guerre
d'Afghanistan où les drones américains
pilotés à distance effectue des tirs de
missiles de plus en plus nombreux il
faut comprendre qu'à ce moment là c'est
drone sont d'abord vus par beaucoup
d'Américains comme des armes
révolutionnaires en effet ils permettent
de mener la guerre sans mettre
plonger forcément les soldats qui ont
moins besoin d'aller sur le terrain et
l'opinion publique s'inverse assez
rapidement lorsque certains médias ou
encore ONG de défense des droits humains
comment ça démontré que ces frappes de
drone provoquent en réalité aussi des
victimes collatérales et ne tue pas
uniquement des terroristes les drones
ravivent alors la colère des antidaires
et notamment auprès des jeunes
générations il y a des travaux et des
enquêtes sur ce sujet vraiment très
intéressantes que je vous invite à voir
en description chez mes ça vous
intéresse du coup des ONG du monde
entier commencent à se mobiliser pour
empêcher le développement de ces armes
[Musique]
ce que vous venez de voir c'est un spot
de campagne du collectif Stop qui leur
robots une coalition qui réunit plus de
180 ONG dans le monde et qui comme son
nom l'indique s'opposent au
développement des robots tueurs
soulève de nombreux défis pour
l'humanité politiquement juridiquement
éthiquement il y a des dizaines de
questions encore en suspens et si dans
l'utilisation des armes plus classiques
y compris d'ailleurs des drones pilotés
à distance il y a toujours des humains
pour diriger et appuyer sur la gâchette
à qui reviendra la responsabilité de la
mort si la décision de tuer quelqu'un
est prise par un robot autonome
j'espère en tout cas que vous aurez
compris avec cette vidéo à quel point
ces armes notamment ces drones peuvent
changer à avoir un impact important sur
un conflit cette vidéo vous a plu pour
nous soutenir n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ne pas louper aussi les
vidéos suivantes on a lancé une nouvelle
chaîne cette chaîne youtube il y a
quelques mois qui vient en complément de
la chaîne des actus du jour pour vous
apporter justement des reportages des
interviews des formats un petit peu
différents de ce qu'on peut faire sur la
chaîne des actus du jour pensez donc à
vous abonner mais c'est pas encore le
cas ne serait-ce que pour nous soutenir
merci aussi à l'école de drone
ukrainienne qui nous a permis de faire
ce tournage merci aussi Anaïs qui est
journaliste au sein de l'équipe et qui a
travaillé avec moi sur cette vidéo y
compris sur le terrain enfin si vous
voulez creuser cette question de la
guerre en Ukraine on a publié notre
reportage sur notre chaîne YouTube cette
même chaîne youtube il y a quelques
jours le lien est directement en
description ou alors une fiche apparaît
actuellement à l'écran prenez soin de
vous prenez soin de nos proches et on se
dit à très vite